whether or not we have a new team soon
new research shows the Valley Sports
Renaissance has brought in millions of
dollars hundreds of thousands of
Spectators and a new Need for increased
Transportation eight news now reporter
Ryan Matthey continues our team coverage
tonight he's right outside Allegiant
stadium and delves into those numbers
well the largest sporting addition to
Las Vegas was this 1.9 billion dollar
Stadium behind me here it is the second
most costly stadium in the NFL across
the country the question is not if the
sporting industry will continue to grow
here but what needs to be done now to
avoid the growing pains
weather on the ice
on the track
or on International TV Las Vegas
solidifying the title of sports capital
of the world we can do a UFC event on
top of a football event on top of NASCAR
on top of Shriners which actually is
going to happen again this year the
topic of the sports and Society
conference at UNLV what impact has
professional sports had on Southern
Nevada about five percent of all uh
spending generated from tourism in
southern Nevada we can tie back to sport
Andrew Woods director of UNLV Center for
business and economic research delved
into that through this recently
published report roughly one in 20
visitors are coming here which is for
the sole purpose of sporting events he
found over 285
000 spectator seats in the valley 39
significant events planned through 2024
with out of town visitors spending over
1.8 billion dollars last fiscal year for
visitors they tend to stay longer and
they bring a bigger group and they also
spend a little bit more than the
traditional weekend warrior visitor here
in Las Vegas and with tourism and
population booms on the horizon Woods
points to Transportation or the lack
thereof of what's needed to support this
supporting our visitors so that they can
come and visit for the weekend and get
home and make their flights but it's
also for our locals so that we're not
discouraged from coming to a game
because it takes four hours that we
don't have choice and how we get there
so the Tesla Loop even the brightline
proposal from California to Las Vegas
are some of the attempts that Woods list
of increasing our capacity for
transportation here but he says really
none of them meet the mass transit needs
now keep in mind other UNLV research
forecasts that 700 000 more people will
be living here by 2040 and then annual
tourism is expected to rise to 50
million people